hidey ho reject those we're gonna watch
ourselves some brooklyn nine-nine today
two by sixteen uh i wanna thank maria
hammond once again we're in a nakatoni
plaza beanie in honor of jake peralta's
love for zaddah haad guys if you could
go ahead and hit that like button and
that would be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next brooklyn nine-nine is up
here on the channel we'll be doing them
weekly full length watch long sync up
with the time code over at our patreon
page of course thank you to all who
become superjects and checking out all
the stuff we gotta do with that yeah i
said that and also the boys of our
prepper thanks for helping us edit down
these highlights boys let's get to it
i've been tracking the club owner
vladimir drogic aka the dragon aka my
first perp with a cool nickname what
about el babosso the dagger yeah it
turns out rosa was lying about that
elbow both boso actually means the slug
i refer to myself as elbaboso to several
beautiful latina ladies oh that's your
type isn't it jakey like sophia
hey joe be careful buddy
i'm sorry what's going on who are you
drexel with the organized crime unit i'm
here for the mayor case materials oh are
you well we'll see what my captain has
to say about this thank you for taking
the
i gave you two weeks i'm done fending
off the organized crime unit squad since
peralta's briefing was cut short you can
all use this time to clean up your desks
look at this place half-eaten food
crumpled tissues pictures of your
families what's wrong with people if you
love someone you'll remember what they
look like
what is going on him rubber band ball
keep your bands in a box or a bag
since you all apparently have time to
play throw
i'm cancelling overtime for the month
effective immediately get to work
b-ball these bands what is this problem
i don't know
he's like me monday wednesdays and
fridays
maybe he's having problems with kevin i
just think it's so much more relaxing
being a cop than a youtuber
absolutely the wednesday incident hey
just closed my 10th felony of the month
and i thought we could celebrate might i
remind you that this is a police
precinct and it's 10 o'clock in the
morning i thought you might say that
that's why this is non-alcoholic
sparkling cider there's absolutely
nothing you could be mad about
wow
you got your bank robber went home last
night no overtime just me and some brie
and i cracked it
so here he is the thug that's been
terrorizing the city say hello marvin
hello
he couldn't pull off the cap on his
medicine i can hear you sorry this guy
is a ruthless criminal i'm sorry sir is
this going to take long because i was
hoping to buy some slacks this afternoon
i like
it's an act my system is a little
unsettled
cause i trouble you for ginger era oh of
course sir we'll get that in a comfy
chair for you to sit in yeah
lies
i rob those banks
but i like to see the tellers squirm
i get off on violence
[Laughter]
go oh thank you so much you're such a
doll
i must pay you no no no
jesus
i think you remind me of my
granddaughter
oh you are so sweet
i haven't got a granddaughter
[Laughter]
we have a tape recorder man i'm not
gonna discuss my whole life with you
we're not friends we're not family
you're not my husband
that's hurtful i thought we had a
special pond i was your secret santa
last year and i already thanked you for
the who farted baseball cap
never wear it
i spent a lot of time cultivating a good
relationship with kevin he finally calls
me gina instead of miz linetti all right
fine then i'm calling in my chit
remember when i got you this job you
said omg jake i owe you one sounds like
her yeah it does a receipt for almonds
yeah i just thought it would be more
dramatic to slide something across the
table it wasn't but since i made that
promise fine
hey kevin gina good to see you jake's
here too
yo
no he was already upset when he got to
work he was anger articulating coat coat
jacket coat is this a police precinct
[Laughter]
you know kevin maybe if we figure out
what caused raymond's bad mood we could
fix it great idea gina
you're going to jail my friend in a
trolley named charles that trolley
trolleys are cool they have the bells
you know what just i'm with you charles
team trolley
thank you ladies for bringing a little
sunshine into my great life
you want to know what i'm going to do
with the money i stole
prostitutes
you heard him tell me you hurt him what
son of a [ __ ] phone recorder oh peralta
you are so old to behave the way you do
oh
what i'm sure he vents about everyone on
the squad nope just you damn it diane
what are you doing after this
smooth
well according to his sketch his next
stop was his weekly painting class
painting class
can i guess what he paints pictures of
pie charts multiple still likes are this
grey rock
[Laughter]
did he seem like something or someone
had him in a bad mood it was his day to
pick the music and he chose haydn so he
was in a good mood or a bad mood a great
mood jake oh you're jake damn it what
are you doing after this gerald
[Laughter]
as usual raymond was the king of the
quasar and i got in a few good opioids
so just a bunch of normal worries
you haven't um
i'm sorry i need to leave excuse me oh
no what do you know kevin
he's having an affair three mornings
this week he told me he was fencing with
dan why would he do that why would he
lie to me i don't know maybe it's
connected to his bad mood my husband
does not lie to him this investigation
of yours was a bad idea i'm going home i
have to sort this out with raymond
goodbye peralta you've made things worse
oh oh got lynette gina privilege revoked
you're not supposed to be here and the
captain's at a new level of anger
constant smiling
oh
i'm gonna get that loudly old geezer to
admit on camera that he robbed those
banks
he just died
what
he just died
i don't buy it
hello gina captain holt is that you
oh no it's jake nailing your voice
exactly right the trick is to find a key
phrase you know exactly how he'd say
mine is peralta that's enough
[Laughter]
come with me young wise assistant let us
walk in this direction
oh a hot dog should i stop not for one
of those i wouldn't damn it's morphing
into british do your catchphrase peralta
that's enough
personal photos are down kitchen is
spotless and i got the silver painted
brake dancer
to move its very loud boom box elsewhere
wow
yes you beat them in a dance-off no i
destroyed them there's absolutely
nothing here that will set off hope
yeah this is your fault search give me
that
i'm just
holding the road there
stepping on some oatmeal
[Laughter]
i can't believe that you of all people
are my biggest problem today jeffords
oh
i retraced his steps and found security
footage after he left fencing three
shady guys followed him into an alley
one of them had a knife that's why he's
been in such a bad mood he's a police
captain that got mugged he's embarrassed
oh my goodness
gary
what are you doing in my house how do
you get it there i know
what did you say to him captain it's
okay there's nothing to be embarrassed
about i'm not embarrassed and i wasn't
mugged three men tried to mug me but i
fought them off injuring two of them
yeah
damn that frame rate why would you keep
this from me and why would you lie about
going to fencing because he couldn't go
because he's injured i wasn't injured i
was lightly stabbed oh
raymond you are unbelievable
you cannot muck around in people's
private lives get out of my house
uh get into your car i'll go
[Laughter]
oh boo i guess you need to think of some
professional way to make it up to him
wait a minute gina that's it
i just had an idea
peralta you're a genius
who is that scarjo
guard you he gave me money for the
ginger ale after you insisted he was
guilty i went back and checked his
dollar serial numbers matched the stolen
bills you brought in the right guy
you're a damn good cop will i know no
one listens
we id'd one of the mopes and that's his
apartment
i thought maybe you would want to do the
honors and you think this will make
everything you did better well
maybe it was gina's ideas it will gina
had nothing to do with it
when those men came at me i acted like i
was a 20 year old i took a stupid risk
and i got myself stabbed
i was in pain
and frustrated about lying to the man i
love kevin yes
i wasn't mad at you i was mad at myself
and i took it out on the squad
peralta
you're a genius
[Laughter]
and you are each allowed two personal
photographs two trinkets and three
assorted knickknacks you know what just
follow sergeant jeffords lee he always
knows how to keep this place running
smoothly nice no
oh kevin let me just get my coat hello
peralta
gina oh
thank you we're back on a first name
basis kevin i am unable and unwilling to
discuss personal matters with you i'm
aware of that yes in any case thank you
for your help i brought you both gifts
original raymond holt oh
i want one
ah rock 59 and
367. those are good rocks
[Laughter]
i want a gray rock t-shirt
gosh
yeah you know i i
i just want to be a cop yeah i just want
to
if it's anything like this which it is
absolutely which i imagine this is this
is fire from someone's real life
experiences and being a cop
i i just i i
that's it i'm just coming to cop calling
in i'm becoming a cop you're cut out for
this
oh yeah i feel like anyone isn't anybody
yeah i mean really all it takes is a
good witch and you could be a cop yeah
as long as you got the banter
ah that was so pleasant that was so
pleasant i'm so glad
i'm so glad that they were able to
finally see
that old man was a robber all along
yes that was very gratifying great clue
planted in there you think for someone
that genius they wouldn't use a dollar
bill yeah but maybe he likes the chase
you know that's true that's why i robbed
7-elevens oh yeah i just take an egg
salad sandwich
shove it right in here scrunch it down
where it pops out of the plastic yeah
yeah
just pretend like you got a triangular
bicep as i'm checking out just got some
excellent protruding out of my sleeve
nah dude that's just creatine it's just
that's just like stray strands of
protein you get it you know how muscles
because you know as a cop you got to be
ripped you got to have your muscles
you've heard the other egg salad man
i was like i didn't do that one person
was stepping on my turf that's 7-eleven
and then a copycat thief oh [ __ ] that's
right you found it what do you know who
knows maybe i'll steal other kinds of
sandwiches and make you look bad i'm
already on the tunas
oh you're you're stepping on my
territory
i figured i knew one day
that's right this is good and then and
then we would have the confrontation
here on camera yeah that's so for the
audience yeah the only way we have
confrontations anymore
is if uh people can see it and we can
get views yeah and then the other
storyline here
of uh holt's dealing with uh the i i
think the some of my favorite episode
structures or or plots are the ones when
they are trying to figure out like
why is holding a bad mood you know like
or jake gets like way too involved
because it does show how well he knows
holt to the point where
he can tell there's something else
bothering him but uncovering the mystery
of it is such a blast and i like
whenever you get these little glimmers
of hope these shades
that kevin might actually be warming up
to the guy
[Music]
well you know by the time we see kevin
with peralta again it's just going to
reset back it's going to go right back
it always ends with him maybe just maybe
yeah maybe and then it no it just every
time we check back again kevin wants
nothing to do with him kevin is not in
enough episodes to make that happen yet
yeah for the art to feel the actual yeah
when did it become cool yeah yeah so we
need that but yeah that was a really
funny episode and uh
like jake's peralta and i sound like joe
from family guy it's okay as i'm trying
to do jake's impression of peralta
i'm jake's version of uh yeah greg
you're a genius
yeah that sounds more like jake's
impression of okay i thought i was
following george territory
yes
yeah yeah yeah you know andre brauer is
a lot like uh george takei just just
with more
stank
yeah
yeah there's a lot of care a lot i like
that we get to see hold [ __ ] up as a
leader yeah it's been a theme this
season
taking out your own personal issues out
on those around you yeah how else are
you supposed to handle it
i don't know you got to get them out
somehow and that seems like the most
effective way actually talk about it
with the person or you're crazy are you
a [ __ ]
oh my god you look weak tmi you look
weak i always say mask it with anger
because that right there you get some
kind of release and you don't even
really have to deal with what's going on
oh yeah because it's all in the anger
and then it feels like it's other
people's doing destruction
dude totally distract yourself from
emotional pain with physical pain
it's like biting your tongue or or like
a finger you know oh yeah yeah
or when when you want like a really
freezing cold sensation yeah like when
you go to 7-eleven to rob a slurpee
definitely and you shove it in your
pocket uh-huh and then it reaches down
your inner thigh yeah yeah oozes into
your shoes yeah oh my god totally
uncomfortable it hurts but for a moment
there i totally forget about all my
mistakes that's right that's right and
for a second i was transported to some
snowy alps somewhere yeah that's hurting
and i'm painting and i'm not wearing the
proper protective gear this is not how i
want my vacation to end so then all my
problems are fixated on that
physical uncomfortableness
so yeah i think we've learned a lot
today we did we definitely learned a lot
yeah
that you should mask everything with
anger steal and steal some stuff from
7-eleven because it's really easy not to
get caught you can even talk about it
publicly on youtube yeah
you can talk about it while you're doing
it in the store yeah they don't know the
clerk will be like hey you do well you
be thank you thanks for the best windows
so they're usually just nodding their
heads thinking like i don't know what
he's saying but he paid same time
tomorrow okay mm-hmm yeah
i think we've said everything needs to
be said i think we've covered the entire
episode we broke it down it's good it
was really funny we had a great time and
uh hey there's nothing more to really
say is there it's shortest review ever
yeah and boy did we review it we did we
definitely covered it from beginning to
end and we reviewed it two whole plot
lines down yeah two more to go next week
and also i'm glad boyle got to catch
someone mm-hmm yeah
he's a good cop good cobb and peralta is
a genius he is he is and he and holt are
best friends now
all right guys well thanks for being
here hey let's do a page
pandemic jones pandemic jones this
episode covered paintings and you know
who i'd like to do a painting of
you i want to do a painting of you
watching us
on your television checking out our
reactions you know what i would do with
your painting i'd probably half-ass what
you look like i'm really just kind of
it's
beyond it's probably gonna be like
closer to a stick figure but i'm gonna
bring such fine attention to detail on
john and i we're really gonna pop and
stand out when i give you this painting
of you and that's how i'm gonna pitch it
i'm gonna label it as i did a portrait
of you
you're gonna be unrecognizable but we
instant recognition right away when you
see our faces you're gonna go that's
craig and john a photo your family won't
even they're gonna be like that could
literally be anyone and i'm gonna be
like but that's part of the point of
pandemic jones he could be anyone you
could see find a way to just blend into
any environment thus that's the
insidious nature
of a pandemic
i think i made it make sense yeah thanks
pj for being part of our patreon page
for so long and helping us kick off 2022
buddy you rock keep the pandemic going
not the real one
but the joy
[Music]